"THE FIVE" LIVE FROM NASHVILLE,
TENNESSEE, .
DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA ARE
MELTING DOWN AHEAD OF THE
MUELLER REPORT BEING RELEASED ON
THURSDAY.
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN STEVE:
ACTUALLY USING THE DEVASTATING
NOTRE DAME FIRE TO ATTACK
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> AT THIS PRESIDENT HAS DONE
AND WHAT HE'S DONE TO THE
CONSTITUTION, THE PEOPLE'S
RESPECT FOR OUR GOVERNMENT, WHAT
HE'S DONE TO THE CONSTITUTION
AND THE RULE LAW IS AS BAD AS
THAT FIRED IT TO NOTRE DAME.
HE IS TORCHING THE ENTIRE
STRUCTURE OF GOVERNMENT AND THE
PEOPLE'S RESPECT FOR IT.
HE WAS NOT EXONERATED, SAYS
MUELLER.
MUELLER WAS MORE ABOUT THAT THAN
BARR.
"THE FIVE" WAS A HIT MAN HIRED
TO DO HIS JOB AND HE'S DOING HIS
JOB.
>> Jesse: THE LIBERAL MEDIA
LASHING OUT AT PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND CLAIMING THAT AG BILL BARR
IS BEHIND SOME SORT OF COVER UP.
>> HE IS PANICKING.
IT'S A LAUGHABLE FREAK OUT ON
DONALD TRUMP'S PART.
HE IS SPITTING OUT EVERYTHING HE
CAN.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE ON
SPRING BREAK.
CONGRESS IS ON RECESS.
THEY ARE PUTTING THIS RELEASE AS
LATE AS POSSIBLE BEFORE EASTER
WEEKEND WHEN THEY MIGHT GET THE
LEAST AMOUNT OF ATTENTION.
>> YOU'VE GOT TO WONDER WHY HE'S
DOING ALL THIS.
WHAT HE'S DOING IT NOW.
IS IT BECAUSE HE'S GOT REASON TO
FEAR WHAT'S COMING?
>> BARR WANTS TO USE THIS
PROCESS TO TRY TO PLAY DOWN THE
REPORT HEADING INTO A FRIDAY
HOLIDAY WEEKEND RATHER THAN PLAY
IT UP.
>> Jesse: ONE OF THE REASONS
WE WANTED TO GET OUT OF
NEW YORK CITY AND OUT OF THE
CITY WAS TO FIND OUT WHAT OTHER
PEOPLE ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE
TALKING ABOUT AND IT'S NOT THE
MUELLER REPORT.
>> Greg: NO, THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT YOUR HAIR.
IF YOUR HAIR GOT ANY HIGHER, IT
WOULD HAVE ITS OWN ALTITUDE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON.
THE FUNNY THING IS, THIS MUELLER
FREAK OUT, REPORTS COMING OUT ON
THURSDAY.
IT'S LIKE THE MEDIA, THEY ARE
LIKE DRUG ADDICTS WHO FOUND OUT
THERE'S A NEW CHEAPER DRUG ON
THE STREET AND THEY ARE GETTING
THE CRAVING.
THEY HAVE THE MUELLER CRAVING.
THEY SHOULD JUST QUIT COLD
TURKEY.
THE PROBLEM IS THEY CAN'T QUIT
COLD TURKEY BECAUSE THEY SOLD
THEIR AUDIENCE A BILL OF GOODS.
THEY'VE MADE IT SOUND -- THEY
MEET THE MUELLER REPORT INTO THE
BIG "GAME OF THRONES" BUT IT
TURNS OUT IT'S GOING TO BE LIKE
BOBBY EWING'S DREAM.
YOU WAKE UP AND NOTHING'S GONNA
BE THERE AND WHAT ARE THEY GONNA
TELL THEIR VIEWERS WHICH ARE
HEMORRHAGING?
CNN LAW LOSING VIEWERS BECAUSE
THEY LIED TO THEM ABOUT THIS.
>> Jesse: LOOKS LIKE THE
AUDIENCES AS OF CNN AND MSNBC
ARE HOOKED ON FAKE NEWS, AS GREG
SAYS.
THEY NEITHER FIX AND THEY HAVE
TO HEAR SCANDALOUS
CONSPIRATORIAL REPORTS OR
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO WATCH.
>> Dana: I THINK THAT'S WHY
YOU GET THE HYPERBOLE.
YOU HAVE THE COMPARISON TO THE
BURNING OF NOTRE DAME WHICH WAS
FELT WORLDWIDE.
IT WAS LIKE A PUNCH, WATCHING
THAT BEAUTIFUL BUILDING, THE
PLACE WERE SO MANY RELIGIOUS
EXPERIENCES HAVE HELD THROUGHOUT
THE YEARS, INCLUDING PEOPLE WHO
WERE SITTING RIGHT HERE.
IT GETS TO BE A LITTLE
OVER-THE-TOP AND IF YOU CRY WOLF
THAT MANY TIMES AND THEN THERE'S
NOTHING, THEN YOU DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO RUN ON.
>> Donna: I THINK EVERYBODY
WANTS TO SEE IT FOR THIS COMING
FRIDAY, I HAVE NOTHING TO DO.
I DON'T HAVE TO COOK.
I HAVE THIS REMARKABLE CHICKEN.
I'M ON A CRASH DIET.
I HAVE THE MUNCHIES AND I AM
WAITING THE MUELLER REPORT.
>> Greg: SEE?
I TELL YOU.
>> Donna: I'VE GOT THE
MUNCHIES.
420 MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
>> Greg: THE MUELLER MUNCHIES.
>> Donna: I WANT TO READ IT
PAGE BY PAGE.
IF YOU GIVE ME SOME LIQUOR, I'LL
READ IT QUICKER.
>> John: WHOA, WELCOME TO
NASHVILLE.
>> Donna: I'VE BEEN HANGING
OUT WITH YOU ALL DAY SO I KNOW
WHAT TO EXPECT.
I'M GLAD IT'S COMING OUT.
I'M GLAD WE GET AN OPPORTUNITY
TO LOOK AT IT AND FINALLY SAY
ONCE AND FOR ALL THE COUNTRY WAS
UNDER ATTACK.
WE KNOW WHAT HAPPENED IN 2016
AND PERHAPS WE CAN LEARN FROM
THE MISTAKES OF 2016 I DON'T LET
THEM GET REPEATED IN 2020.
>> Jesse: WE DO KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED IN 2016.
TRUMP WON.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
JOHN RICH.
>> Donna: AND WE ALSO KNOW
THAT VLADIMIR PUTIN WANTED TRUMP
TO WIN.
>> Jesse: LET'S GET TO JOAN.
>> Donna: I WANT TO GET TO
JOHN BECAUSE I AM ENJOYING HIM.
HE DOESN'T HAVE TO WEAR A HAT OR
COVER UP THAT HAIR.
I WANT TO SEE IT BECAUSE I DO
BELIEVE AT THE END OF THE DAY WE
AS AMERICANS MUST UNDERSTAND HOW
TO DEFEND OUR COUNTRY FROM
FUTURE CYBER ATTACKS.
THAT SAID, BROTHER JOHN.
>> John: YES, MA'AM.
>> Jesse: TAKE IT AWAY.
>> John: I THINK THAT'S NOT
WHAT YOUR AVERAGE EVERYDAY
AMERICAN CARES ABOUT.
THAT'S WHAT I THINK.
I THINK THEY CARE ABOUT WHAT
THEIR TAX RATE IS.
I THINK THEY CARE ABOUT, DID
THEY GET THEIR JOB BACK OR KEEP
A JOB THEY HAD.
IF THEY DID, DID THEIR WAGES GO
UP?
THAT'S WHAT I THINK WHEN YOU GO
BACK TO THE BERNIE SANDERS PIECE
HOW HE SOLD ALL THESE BOOKS.
HOW DO YOU THINK PEOPLE HAVE
MONEY TO BUY ALL HIS BOOKS?
THEY GOT THEIR TAXES?
WHETHER THEY KNOW THAT OR NOT,
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED.
I GREW UP IN A DOUBLE WIDE
TRAILER IN TEXAS, NOTHING FANCY.
I SEE ALL THE STUFF GOING ON AND
I KNOW THAT'S HOW THE MULTITUDE
OF AMERICANS ACTUALLY FEEL.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THIS
REPORT.
IT'S A MEDIA THING THAT NONE OF
US REALLY CARE ABOUT.
>> Greg: AND JESSE, YOU KEEP
YOUR HAIR AND A DOUBLE WIDE
TRAILER.
>> Jesse: MY HAIR IS ABOUT AS
HIGH AS COLORADO.
>> John: THE HIGHER THE HAIR,
THE CLOSER TO GOD.
>> Donna: BUT IT'S ALL LEGALLY
YOUR HAIR.
>> Jesse: LEGAL, NOT EDIBLE.
>> John: COME ON DOWN.
>> Greg: I THINK THAT VIOLATES
SOME HUMAN RESOURCES LAW.
GOING TO END UP GETTING SUED.
>> John: NOT IN NASHVILLE.
>> Dana: HERE'S WHAT I THINK.
THIS REPORT WHEN IT COMES OUT ON
THURSDAY, YOU WILL HAVE
BREATHLESS REPORTING.
I FIND IT HARD TO BELIEVE THAT
BILL BARR, THE NEW
ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO HAS THIS
AMAZING TRACK RECORD IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., CAME OUT SO
THERE'S NO COLLUSION AND
BASICALLY NOTHING ON
OBSTRUCTION.
I FIND IT VERY HARD TO BELIEVE
THAT HE WASN'T BEING TRUTHFUL.
NOW THE MEDIA HAS BUILT IT UP